governor ron desantis has officially
signed into law the parental rights in
education bill which prohibits teachers
from preaching transgenderism in
kindergarten through third grade
classrooms
the law is extremely popular among
voters more than 60 percent of whom
support the law but it's extremely
unpopular among the degenerate perverts
who rule over us the walt disney company
a corporation exclusively focused on
entertaining children
is furious that five-year-olds won't be
taught transgenderism in florida schools
disney told the daily wire that quote
florida's hb 1557 also known as the
don't say gay bill should never have
been passed and should never have been
signed into law our goal as a company is
for this law to be repealed by the
legislature or struck down in the courts
and we remain committed to supporting
the national and state organizations
working to achieve that
in other words
this 200 billion dollar kids programming
company
is going to focus its vast resources on
undermining parents and peddling
transgenderism
to kids
president biden promised to
take the full force of the federal
government and devote it to undermining
florida parents claiming that supposedly
transgender first graders quote deserve
to be affirmed
in the sexual delusions planted in them
by creepy teachers and not to be outdone
nancy pelosi has claimed that quote this
cruel legislation is an affront to our
nation's cherished values and sends a
harmful message to our children
but contrary to whatever nancy pelosi
might think
convincing five-year-olds to chop off
their genitals does not rank among our
nation's cherished values
it never has
it does not now and i certainly hope it
never will
it's sick
it's downright demonic and the vast
majority of americans know it
unfortunately the people who control
almost all the power in this country
support it
and the fight for parents rights to
protect their kids from these psychos is
just getting started i'm michael it's
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from kyle ruggs who
says the only thing that the smith's
relationship is not open for
is jokes that's not nice
that's not nice it's true
and it's harsh
but it's not
nice okay do you know what is nice
though fabric right now go to
meetfabric.com
knowles because you love your kids i
love my kids i'm a man with one young
son and another one on the way and kids
are wonderful and kids are expensive
with fabric protecting your family with
term life insurance
is not expensive it's surprisingly
affordable and you've got to do it it is
the responsible thing to do you've got
your kids you want to make sure they're
protected god forbid something happens
to you fabric was built specifically for
parents to help you manage your family's
financial future like a parenting pros
stress free fabrics new lower prices
mean significant savings over other
providers
with great policies like a million
dollars in coverage for less than one
dollar a day do it right now do not put
it off it takes less than 10 minutes to
apply
it is so important to protect your
family do it you do it in just 10
minutes apply today at meat fabric dot
com slash knowles that's m e e t fabric
dot com slash knowles to start
protecting your family today meat fabric
dot com slash knowles fabric insurance
agency policies issued by bantus life
not available in new york and montana
price is subject to underwriting and
health questions
ron desantis
governor of florida best governor in
america he is handling the parental
rights in education controversy
as best as he possibly could
he is handling the sloganeering from the
democrats the crazy don't say gay slogan
that has nothing to do with the bill
he's handling the immense pressure from
corporations including disney including
corporations that are really prominent
in florida he's handling the pressure
from the federal government exactly as
he should and what is his response his
response is stand firm don't back down
and tell your opponents to pound sand
we will continue to recognize that in
the state of florida parents have a
fundamental role in the education health
care and well-being of their children we
will not move from that i don't care
what corporate media outlets say i don't
care what hollywood says i don't care
what big corporations say
here i stand
i'm not backing down
here i stand i'm not backing down not
only is this the right thing to do
because it is
it is a national scandal that these
creeps are being allowed to indoctrinate
five-year-olds and transgenderism not
only is desantis doing the morally right
thing
he's doing the politically smart thing
he's doing the only thing that will not
destroy his political career so often
the squishes believe ah
gosh i was standing firm on not not
letting these creeps trans the kids but
then i got a call from the big
corporation ah then i got then i got a
threat from the federal government uh
maybe i'll back down a little bit you
saw this with asa hutchinson in arkansas
you saw this with christy gnome in south
dakota although she she then flipped her
opinion initially she was going to let
dudes compete with women in girls sports
in college
because presumably because some
corporate leaders called her and then
she realized that was destroying her
political career so then she's tried to
reverse course desantis is standing firm
because it's the right thing to do and
in this case at least the right thing to
do is the politically smart thing to do
what the libs are telling us on this
transing the kids issue
is that it's not happening
it's not hap the florida don't say gay
bill which is really the parental rights
and education bill which really just
says that you can't teach five to
nine-year-olds about transgenderism and
creepy sex stuff they're saying it's not
happening
it's not real it's not it's it's
addressing a problem that does not exist
oh okay great well then then what's the
big deal
if if it's addressing a problem that
does not exist
then why are you so insistent that we
repeal the bill
it's okay it's not going to have any
effect right democrats
no what the democrats are saying is it's
it's addressing a problem that does not
exist and it's really good that it does
exist no uh what we're not transiting
the kids in kindergarten and it's
essential that we trans the kids in
kindergarten
which is it they're speaking out of both
sides of their mouths well we've got the
receipts we know that this sort of thing
is happening there's a story out of the
austin independent school district
so this is not not just florida this is
now in texas texas texas is supposed to
be a very conservative state in the
austin independent school district
a teacher
has sent some internal messages that
were obtained by one of our favorite
twitter accounts libs of tick tock
which
reveal that she is preaching
lgbtqia lmnop stuff in the classroom and
transgenderism specifically in the
classroom
and that
20 of this teacher's 32 4th grade
students
have come out to her as queer
must be something in the water in austin
maybe alex jones is on to something this
is what the teacher says
teacher was very upset
that
for one of the
multiple
gay pride celebrations in this public
school in this elementary school they
called it a wellness walk and the
teachers complaining because that's not
gay enough so the teacher says well i
understand that wellness walk is
something that was previously in motion
to promote health and fitness into
something we want to continue it really
takes away from the experience of
celebrating pride
to couple the two the first pride was a
riot it's not not enough to just welcome
love and celebrate queer folks and then
this fourth grade teacher puts an x
instead of a ks on folks because well
this teacher knows a lot about radical
sexual ideologies the teacher does not
know a lot about grammar that's
unfortunate probably explains our
educational situation in america your
allyship should always lead you to
activism speaking up and fighting for
what's right even when it feels
uncomfortable we can't choose in and out
of our protest spaces okay so saying the
the
gay pride parades taking place in the
elementary school are not they're not
radical enough so we need more
explicitly
sexual
parades in the elementary school
and then here's the kicker out of the 32
students that i teach
20 of them are
lgbtqia plus and have come out to me
i feel that we need to do better for
them to affirm our students we need to
publicly announce what we had this
morning was a pride parade our students
were aware and paying attention
20
out of 32 students
are
lgbtqia these we're talking about eight
and nine year olds
what are the odds
one
one the first problem with this
is that what this teacher is bragging
about is that eight-year-olds have
secrets with her secrets that they they
maybe they don't tell their parents
sexual secrets that they're regularly
discussing with their creepy degenerate
pervert of a teacher
but then you have the statistical
implausibility let's call it that 20 out
of the 32
eight and nine-year-olds that this woman
i said i hope it's a woman could create
it's even creepier if it's a man that
this individual
is
supposed to be teaching and instructing
and leading
20 out of 32
all have the same
weird extremely rare sexual condition
isn't that a little strange
that well it's not strange when you
realize that eight and nine year olds
don't know anything and they just play
pretend all the time and they're
extremely impressionable and full of
delusion and this teacher is obviously
grooming them this teacher is obviously
implanting these crazy ideas in their
heads
just like i remember i remember in i
don't know kindergarten or first grade i
learned what an archaeologist was that
we we had a a little lesson in the
classroom about archaeologists and then
three-quarters of the students decided
they wanted to be archaeologists someday
we do because we oh i get what do you do
you dig up dinosaur bones cool we're all
going to be archaeologists that's what
we are now that's our identity because
we heard it because we're very
impressionable and it was something
novel and and the teacher
seemed to suggest this was a cool thing
the
lgbtqia ideology in this fourth-grade
classroom it's just
it's just today's version of teachers
describing what it is to be an
archaeologist or anything else
except the consequences of this
are extraordinarily grave because the
consequences of this
increasingly peddled by our left-wing
establishment is that we've got to put
these little kids on hormone blockers
we've got to mutilate their bodies we've
got to permanently destroy their lives
because of the sick sexual fantasies and
perversions of these radical leftist
teachers but don't worry it's not
happening we got to get rid of we've got
to get rid of any bill to protect the
kids from these creeps so says disney so
says our political establishment we
can't have that what's happening to our
country
increasingly it's hard to tell even what
our country is you go to the grocery
store you buy meat it says product of
the usa it's from el salvador well
that's why you got to check out good
ranchers go to goodranchers.com
knowles right now i love good ranchers i
eat it multiple times a week you know
when i was a kid
having steak was a special occasion kind
of thing it was
and we'd get you know we go down to the
local mark and get some steaks but it
was his steak is very expensive
what good ranchers has done which i
think is just so phenomenal is it's made
it affordable such that you can have
steak it doesn't need to just be a once
every couple of months treat you can
have steak regularly you can have it
frankly every week really high quality
steak prime steak better than organic
chicken too i love their chicken and you
can have it regularly you can lock in
your price right now forever it's
already low prices you if you subscribe
to the meat you don't just get a one-off
box if you subscribe you'll lock in your
price forever for life and on top of
that you get a 30 discount on prime
stakes and better than organic chicken
go to goodranchers.com
knowles to save on the quality that
you've been looking for
good ranchers takes the guesswork out of
the grocery store sources everything
from local farms ships it to your door
use code knolls and enjoy your box of
100 american meat and 30 in savings
order now to combat inflation with good
ranchers american meat delivered there's
no sexual indoctrination going on in
kindergartens and
elementary schools and middle schools
that's not happening right it's not
except we know we just heard the story
about the fourth grade teacher in austin
who's obviously grooming these poor
students well it's not just elementary
schools it's middle schools there's a
story out of a new jersey middle school
where the new jersey middle school is
forcing students to learn about
transgender hormone therapy
without parental
notification
this is not in a health class
this is not in
a sex education class
this is in
social studies class the new jersey
public taxpayer-funded middle school is
forcing these students to watch a video
about a
woman a young woman who thinks that
she's a man
injecting herself with a bunch of
hormones and testosterone
to try to
in some slight way better resemble a man
so i wrote a email and i just wanted to
share it
just showing people that you can like
build up the courage to you know um
stand up for yourself in a way that you
know this is what you want to do with
your life i think we should be working
just as hard to mentally accept
ourselves for exactly
who we are yeah i think it's really
important to be mentally sound and safe
and i really feel like i'm gonna have a
better life and feel more comfortable in
my life
if i
accept that i'm a trans man the video is
called 10 years on testosterone details
the transition of
adian dowling through these hormone
injections they didn't notify the
parents
the video video says you can build up
the courage to stand up for yourself in
a way
that this is what you want to do with
your life that's what they're telling to
what 11
year olds 12 year olds 13 year olds
no parental notification because what
the administrators and the
political activists at the school are
thinking is the parents won't like this
we know the parents don't like this
stuff sixty percent of voters in america
support the parental rights and
education bill in florida which they're
calling don't say gay
the vast majority of voters and
certainly the vast vast majority of
parents
do not want teachers indoctrinating
young kids elementary middle school kids
into the sexual ideology and so the
teachers say well if we want to do it
anyway we think it's really important so
we're just not going to tell the parents
we're not and why do they want to do it
the reason they want to do it
has long roots in left-wing political
activism it goes back to
at least to the 1930s to 1940s there was
a guy named wilhelm reich i've mentioned
him on the show before he was this very
creepy german sociologist type who had a
theory that all the problems in the
world from cancer to war to every issue
on earth is due to a lack of orgasms and
so people need to have more sex with all
sorts of people maybe with themselves
they need to just have sex x all the
time
and that will solve the problems in the
world he created this bizarre
pseudo-scientific device called the
orgone accumulator the orgones he
believed were these
sort of mystical
sex energy
molecules that that powered the whole
universe and he had this oregon
accumulator box that very intelligent
popular left-wing people purchased jd
salinger author of catcher in the rye
the uh
norman mailer
the uh all sorts of people
were
woody allen actually made fun of this as
the orgasmatron
bernie sanders wrote essays about this
in the 1960s and 70s i write about it in
my book speechless he wrote all of these
essays about how we need to
make younger and younger people more
comfortable with their sexuality he
talked about little kids being
comfortable with their sexuality because
sex is the one thing that wilhelm reich
and all these creeps got right is sex is
very powerful it is really important to
human nature it it drives a lot of our
desires and our instincts and so if you
can shape
sex in really impressionable people you
can
more easily mold them you can more
easily control them so they're doing it
in elementary schools they're doing at
middle schools they're doing it in high
schools there is a high school in
massachusetts
that is teaching transgenderism the idea
that men can become women magically or
that men secretly are women that is
teaching that as fact
now
one of the arguments you hear sometimes
is well we shouldn't teach this stuff in
elementary school
but we it's okay to teach it in high
school
right actually this is kind of the
argument behind the florida bill the
florida bill says you can't teach this
crap to kindergarten through third
graders but older students they can be
taught this
but of course they shouldn't be taught
this the idea that a biology class is
teaching that men can secretly be women
is contrary to the most basic elements
of biology it's just a lie the students
who are in this class are receiving a
really bad education that's filling
their head with lies and delusions that
can be personally destructive to them
and also just leave them ignorant not
even just ignorant but it'll leave them
being absolutely confident knowing
things that are simply not true this is
according to the new boston post
it reports that needham high school in
needham massachusetts is teaching kids
in biology class that humans who change
their gender as though such a thing were
possible
are no different than animals or plants
who naturally alter their body
composition for the survival of their
species
according to the report this biology
class also requests that students not
use gendered language so don't refer to
him and her that would be very very
wrong during
the section on genetics in order to
create an inclusive
classroom so you're saying that certain
for for certain animals and certain
organisms really for certain organisms
sex is a little more ambiguous you've
got asexual reproduction you've got some
examples of hermaphroditism in
in nature and some can
alter their sex to some degree
and they're saying well transgenderism's
just like that
when a man lops off his genitals and
pretends to be a woman because perverts
filled his head with lies that's just
the same as some
single-celled organism changing some
aspect of its sexuality right
wrong of course this is completely
insane
and so it's frankly the issue with the
florida bill is not that it goes too far
and you're not allowed to say gay or
whatever nonsense the left is peddling
the problem with the florida bill is it
doesn't go nearly far enough third grade
is not nearly far enough to protect
people from the lies being peddled by
these activists and they are lies they
have to lie to make this thing stick
this is a story i've been meaning to get
to it all week but actually it fits
quite now with what we're talking about
when william thomas the hulking dude who
beat all the chicks at the ncaa swim and
dive championship a couple of weeks ago
when he won
one quote unquote it became quite clear
from the pictures of that event that
he's a man he's tall he's heavy he's got
broad shoulders he's got a big adam's
apple he has other protrusions that were
clear in his borat jumpsuit he hasn't
changed a thing about his body he's not
this is why part of me thinks he might
be just a performance artist showing the
absurdity of gender theory because he
just
clearly looks like a man he hasn't
changed his voice the only thing he did
was slightly grow his hair out and then
he put a swim cap on so that didn't even
matter
and the reporting from the establishment
media couldn't bear that
it was too real people would just see
they say wait a second i read in the
newspaper i heard on television
that this man was a demure delicate
little woman
but actually you look at him he's
obviously just a dude he's towering over
these girls so what did nbc news do
when they had a choice between changing
their reporting
and changing the reality of the story
itself what do you think they chose you
know what they chose they tried to
change the reality nbc news the today
show got in a lot of trouble because
they took an image of will thomas
and totally airbrushed it out so all of
the features on thomas that seemed
masculine on this is just his face his
shoulders were even were kind of in the
water so it's really just the face they
just softened all of the features to
make him look more like a woman it was a
really bad
airbrushing job it was a really bad
photoshop job
thankfully thankfully the editors at nbc
are so incompetent that they couldn't do
a good job at it let me tell you if they
had daily wire editors here they would
have it would have been much more
persuasive okay but they've only got
incompetence over there at nbc so it
didn't work you looked at it you said
wait a second that's not
why is it why is it so smooth why is the
lighting like oh because when you look
at the real photo he's obviously a dude
so they have to lie they have to lie
every step of the way they have to lie
in their laws and regulations they've
got a lie in their corporate policies
they've got to lie in photographs okay
because they are so
dead set
on
manufacturing this delusion that we're
all going to live in
this is
this is not a coincidence that we're
dealing with this insane
biological anti-biological ideology at
the same time that we're seeing a major
technological revolution that confuses
reality we've got deep fakes we've got
very high-end video technology we're now
moving into virtual reality in the
metaverse and what the the push is here
for the left is to just reimagine
reality it goes all the way back to one
of john f kennedy's favorite lines which
he stole from george bernard shaw the
socialist playwright who put the words
in the mouth of the serpent in the
garden of eden tempting eve who said
some people see things
that are and say why i dream things that
never were and say why not
this line which the left has used is a
great inspiration for decades this line
comes from the mouth of the freaking
devil this is the great temptation
to live in fantasy to reject the world
that god has given us to reject the real
world as it actually is and close our
eyes and bury our heads in sand and just
live in our own fantasies that's
something that little children do when
they play pretend
now it's the adults who are teaching the
children who are telling them that the
pretend world is real life and that's
extraordinarily dangerous
we need we need to hold on to something
tangible in this world especially as our
money is becoming
valueless as as we're living in all
these this this virtual reality if you
want to grab on something that has
always had value i recommend you check
out birch gold right now stop what
you're doing before inflation gets worse
and text knowles know w l e s to 989898
to get all the info you need inflation
is at seven percent right now okay
thanks to joe biden's insane policies
that means that the paper money in your
wallet is losing value fast
russia's full-on invasion of ukraine
not making things any better actually
worsening the markets decline today an
ounce of gold is worth nineteen hundred
dollars in the year two thousand you
know what it was worth
three hundred dollars what if you had
invested in gold then i've been saying
for years and years now that you can buy
gold from birch gold that it is your
hedge against inflation these are the
guys that i trust well did you know
there's another way to hedge against
inflation
you can buy silver from birch gold
silver and gold silver and gold silver
is also considered real money
historically speaking it's extremely
undervalued right now it's an industrial
metal it's in high demand for everything
from electric cars to solar panels to
everything
demand is only going to rise
protect your savings today text knolls
know w les to 98 98 98 to get a free
info kit on buying gold or silver in a
tax sheltered account there's no
obligation to get this info you just you
get the info
you text knoll scanner wles to 989898
get your free info kit now
on this topic
of transgenderism a little bit of a
hobby horse around here at the daily
wire because it's so outrageous
you may have noticed our pal matt walsh
announced his newest film what is a
woman
can't say much about it but i can
announce his newest venture as a
bestselling author and that would be his
book called you guessed it what is a
woman it's now available for pre-order
what is woman.com also on amazon where
it just hit number eight on the
bestseller charts in the
it hit number eight in the women's
studies category so uh head on over
there pre-order the book uh matt has
been chasing this question for over a
year uh it's extremely important to him
to show the world how easy this question
should be you can help him find an
answer when you pre-order the book what
is a woman at what is a woman.com or on
amazon we'll be right back with a lot
more
speaking of shaving men's faces
nbc news digitally shaved will thomas's
face at the ncaa women's swim meet
well
shaving faces has become a national news
story sometimes
in politics and show business you find
yourself in a position where you are the
news story
and that is where the daily wire finds
itself right now because you know that
uh the god king here jeremy boring
launched a razor company jeremy's razors
he launched this i guess now
multi-million dollar company because of
a mean tweet that was sent to me
i was on candace owens's old show
i
candace made some point about
transgenderism actually i agreed with it
and then some a twitter account with two
followers that i assume is just a
democrat operative account came out and
and tagged harry's and tried to get
harry's to cancel at sponsorship of my
show a sponsorship that began long after
i appeared on the other program everyone
knew my views on this subject and
harry's razors came out and said this is
terrible we condemn these views it's
vile it's awful basically insulting our
entire audience and saying that they're
condemnable deplorable irredeemable
bitter clean awful people and so we
didn't like that around here launch this
razor company jeremy's razors you can
find it at i hate harry's dot com the
razer company has completely exploded
it's now much larger than harry's in
terms of its social media footprint
we've sold about a gazillion razor
subscriptions jeremy just appeared on
tucker tucker loved the idea
for years a company called harry's
razors advertised in the daily wire then
harry's like gillette and so many other
companies in this country
went politically insane harry's
announced it was cutting advertising
with the daily wire because the daily
wire believes in the concept of
biological sex and harry's denounced
that belief is quote inexcusable
so rather than complain about this the
ceo of the daily wire jeremy boring came
up with an alternative he started his
own razor company it's called jeremy's
razors it's already more popular than
harry's we haven't tried the razor can't
vouch for the razor we can't tell you
the launch ad one of the best ever made
yeah i mean it's a joke but that doesn't
mean it isn't real we've absolutely
started our own razer company and in our
first 72 hours we've sold 30 000 razer
kits and razer blade
it subscriptions so great
hot is and i just love it because you're
not just complaining you're providing an
alternative and i think it's beautiful
but i'm also tired of this sort of
non-profit mentality on the right that
responds to every attack with the same
tired sort of cycle of lose complain and
beg for donations that's just a recipe
for failure we have to be constructive
we have to be building a future
this is the key please do not tell
jeremy that i said anything nice about
him i will deny it if you say i was
complimenting him on this show but this
is the whole key tucker hits on it he
alludes to it and then jeremy says it
explicitly tucker says you're not just
complaining you're offering an
alternative
that's the key here
sometimes it's important to complain
not to complain about personal slights
not to complain about you're in traffic
not to complain about the food doesn't
taste good but to complain when it's
constructive
to say there's an injustice happening to
say that there is something wrong that
we need to fix that's sort of
complaining that there's a important
place for that sort of criticism
otherwise we wouldn't know what's wrong
but that's not the end then you've got
to build something and conservatives
have been okay at complaining and
criticizing but we haven't been great at
building things it's an uphill battle
the left controls all the power in this
country but what jeremy was saying is no
no we
we have to start building and the re
part of the reason we haven't built is
this issue of the non-profit mentality
on the right
he's saying
what what happens on the right is that
we try to do something the left beats us
then we whine and moan about it and then
people give us more money
we say this is really really bad it's
getting even worse and then we tug on
the heartstrings of conservative donors
and they give us more money and then we
go fight another losing battle and then
we get more money because if we won the
battle we wouldn't we wouldn't get all
that sweet non-profit money
if we won the battle
then it would be solved you see this
with pro-life advocacy sometimes
this is the fear
with pro-life advocacy when it comes to
actual politicians
politicians
republican politicians make a lot of
money from pro-lifers
they say we've got to stop the radical
abortionists
give me a hundred dollars today and
we're gonna stop him
and then so you give him a hundred
dollars yeah it's a very important issue
killing almost a million babies a year
in this country
but then sometimes those same
politicians will not vote to limit
abortion
they will not vote to get rid of the
problem because then they're getting rid
of their cash cow you get all of these
perverse incentives where the incentives
for a lot of the institutional right is
just to lose and so this is what
jeremy's saying is
we need to change the incentives we need
to realign the incentives so that we are
incentivized to win
we here we're not a non-profit company
obviously we're a pretty profitable
company and so the incentive here is to
win the incentive here is to do
something it's to win at the supreme
court if we hadn't won that supreme
court battle over the osha vaccine
mandate that we brought we ourselves
brought to the court we would have been
screwed we would have been in a really
bad situation they would have fined us
basically to bankrupt the company within
two weeks we would have been in a
horrible so we had to win
the incentive there was to win it's
totally right it's a really really
important thing not just not just for
the razers it's good right i shaved with
the razor today it's a nice razor but
also for what it what it means you've
got a it's got to be a good product it's
got to actually provide value and what
it means the threat that that is posing
to vote corporations like
like disney forget harry's for a second
like disney 200 billion dollar company
that's saying if you don't trans your
kids
if you if florida voters don't let us
trans their kids we're going to spend a
lot of our resources to force them to do
it that is a grave threat to our
republic and we've got to fight back and
you can't just fight back
at the elected level you got to do that
too but you got to fight back in
business you got to fight back in the
world corporation you got to fight back
in every single institution that the
left has conquered
speaking of doing violence to men's
faces
how's that for a transition will smith
has apologized for the slap heard round
the world he actually started to
apologize after he won the best actor
award i didn't even know that he won the
best actor award because no one actually
watched the oscars the other night they
just saw that clip of will smith getting
up and smacking chris rock in the face
for telling a joke about his wife
but i guess he won the best oscar and
then during his acceptance speech will
smith alluded a little bit to kind of
almost start to apologize
now i know
to do what we do
you got to be able to take
abuse you got to be able to have people
talk crazy about you
in this business you got to be able to
have
people disrespecting you
and you got to smile and you got to
pretend like that's okay
but richard williams
and what i loved thank you dee
denzel said to me a few minutes ago he
said at your highest moment be careful
that's when the devil comes for you
[Music]
[Applause]
really good advice
as is usually the case from denzel
washington denzel washington is an
extremely
smart guy
there was actually a clip of denzel
washington he uh i forget when this was
this was a couple of years ago denzel
was asked about some news story about
him that was it's i forget it was
something about his politics he's always
had a reputation as being a little more
conservative than the rest of hollywood
and he just completely scorched the
left-wing media
there's been a lot of buzz about this
fake news you were the subject of a fake
news story oh yeah what they say i was
running for press no no i voted
no what'd
if you don't read the newspaper you're
uninformed if you do read it you're
misinformed
if you don't read the newspaper you're
writing for it if you do read it you're
misinformed uh this is an old quote
though denzel's
in recent years is the one who's made it
quite popular and uh it's wrongly
attributed to mark twain which is funny
because people who read that it's a mark
twain quote in the newspaper are
misinformed but he's totally right if
you don't read the paper you're
uninformed if you do read it you're
misinformed he gives will smith this
good advice at your highest moment
that's when the devil comes for you
that's totally true the devil is just
waiting the devil the devil's a real
person okay antonin scalia
made this point in an interview with new
york magazine some years ago about 10
years ago now
in which
this this silly new york new york
magazine reporter said do you bel you
believe in the devil
you believe in heaven and hell he said i
do i even believe in the devil
do you realize how out of touch you are
with most of america
do you realize how out of touch you are
with most people throughout history
most of whom have believed in the devil
as what is it but baudelaire says the
greatest
trick the devil plays is to convince
people that he doesn't exist
so will smith gets that he starts to
kind of almost apologize now he's issued
a full-on apology
to chris rock he says i'm sorry i i
shouldn't have done it it was wrong i
posted it on instagram now it's even
more embarrassing for will smith because
a clip has just come out of will smith
on the arsenio hall show some years ago
in which he himself makes a joke about a
guy who is bald because he's got
alopecia
he has a rule the bass player he got a
rule he got to wax his head every
morning
he follows the rules man he follows the
rules oh these are jokes come on
see you got too into the characters and
got hurt
you gotta love twitter you gotta love
the internet there is a clip there is a
tweet there is a post for everything in
this clip from some years ago will smith
makes
almost the exact same joke
about this musician that
chris rock made about will smith's wife
and then has almost the exact same
reaction as chris rock chris rock reacts
after will smith smacks him chris rock
says it's just a joke it was a gi joke
it wasn't and then in in this clip on
arsenio hall will smith says it's just a
joke it's just a joke come on man i'm a
comedian i'm just an entertainer here
but of course it wasn't about the joke
it wasn't about chris rock i think
that's why chris rock was so shocked and
frankly why will smith was probably
shocked with himself
i
i think that the smackered around the
world
probably had a little bit more to do
with the fact that will smith's wife has
brutally cuckled him and humiliated him
in public for years at this point and he
feels emasculated and humiliated by that
than it does about chris rock making a
relatively mild joke something and he's
just letting out that anger and that
shame that he feels on chris rock and
why does he feel it the argument that
jada smith and i guess will smith were
making when they aired their dirty
laundry on tv was look this isn't a big
deal oh we have all these cultural
hang-ups over infidelity but come on
that's just that's just old-fashioned
that's just irrational it's fine
we can
you know jada smith she has a kind of
encounter
with this guy that she was sleeping with
she it's a kind of it's a it's a minor
indiscretion it's well but it's fine
and we can let's talk about this openly
there's no shame in that but of course
there is of course there is and of
course will smith is humiliated and i
feel terrible for the guy
i feel genuinely terrible for will smith
because even when chris rock makes the
joke will smith started laughing and
then he looked over at jada smith and
jada didn't like it and i i tell you i
don't like to get into psychobabble much
i could read his mind
you could see the wheels turning in will
smith's head he thought oh i've already
been so emasculated i've already been so
humiliated i've already literally been
cuckolded
before the entire public i'm a very
famous guy huge movie star i've been
as humiliated as you possibly can be to
be a cuckold is one of the most
humiliating things that there is in the
italian culture
i'll tell you with someone of italian
extraction that's it's it's one of the
worst things you can call somebody you
call them a coronuto the sign of the
cuckold actually the the rock and roll
symbol you know where you put your hands
in the air that's an italian symbol for
the evil eye and it's the sign of the
cuckold
you're saying i'm gonna you know i'm
you don't want to be a cuckold you want
you want your enemies to be cuckled i
mean it's so humiliating and he's he's
looking he says god can't do it i can't
let this happen until he goes up and
smacks him then he feels bad about it
it's your highest moment the devil's
going to come and get you
this this will smith
incident people are still talking about
it because it kind of confuses political
lines
you've got some people who are and
to some degree myself included who are
sympathetic with will smith who like the
idea that it's kind of chivalrous to get
up there and defend your woman's honor
how dare you sir i challenge you to a
duel i demand satisfaction
i i am sympathetic to that i don't think
people should be allowed to say whatever
they want i mean there's there's not
even a first amendment protection for
fighting words there's always been a
carve out for fighting words among other
things i talk about this in my book
speechless the founding fathers wouldn't
have rolled over for a joke about a
man's wife they would have smacked him
across the face they probably would have
challenged him to a duel but on the
other hand we're talking about a
comedian here chris rock the guy is paid
to go and tell jokes about celebrities
in the room and not only is will smith a
celebrity but jada smith has made
herself a celebrity she's not exactly a
homemaker she's not donna reed okay
she's not staying at home as a
traditional
stay-at-home wife no she's a public
figure and so she's open to that kind of
public criticism for better and for
worse the problem here
with will smith's reaction
is that it wasn't this principled
totally in controlled dignified response
hello sir i demand satisfaction he lost
his school he was not at all in
self-control and that was even more
humiliating for him
you know who is in self-control
donald trump
donald john trump
our nation's 45th and potentially 47th
president
is in such self-control that he just hit
a hole-in-one while playing a round of
golf
the reason this is a news story well
it's impressive to hit all in one
but the reason it's a news story is not
because trump hit a hole-in-one it's
because of the statement that he issued
trump issues a full press release and
his press releases read kind of like
long tweets ever since he was kicked off
twitter i i want to read it in full if
you'll indulge me i i have to read you
this statement by trump in full he says
many people are asking so i'll give it
to you now it is 100 true while playing
with the legendary golfer ernie ells
winner of four majors and approximately
72 other tournaments throughout the
world g sours winner of the senior u.s
open ken duke and mike goods both
excellent tour players i made a hole in
one
it took place at trump international
golf club in west palm beach florida on
the seventh hole which was playing 181
yards into a slight wind
i hit a five iron which sailed
magnificently into a rather strong wind
with approximately five feet of cut
whereupon it bounced twice and then went
italicized clank
into the hole these great tour players
noticed it before i did because their
eyes are slightly better but on that one
hole only their swings weren't
anyway there's a lot of chatter about it
quite exciting and people everywhere
seem to be asking for the facts
sorry
i'm sorry
it's too good
playing with that group of wonderful
talented players was a lot of fun the
match was ernie and me with no strokes
against gene mike and ken i won't tell
you who won
because i'm a very modest individual and
you you will then say i was bragging and
i don't like people who brag
watch the video here
and then it's a video of trump's
hole-in-one why do i read that one i
read it because it's incredibly funny
and i miss him so much and i just wish
he were on twitter and all of our lives
would be at least 40 percent funnier
and more filled with humor if trump were
still on twitter but the other reason i
mention it
is because this is a man
in self-control
yes he was a billionaire playboy yes
he's had a colorful life
but beyond some minor indiscretions here
there he really is a man in self-control
he doesn't drink he barely sleeps he's a
workaholic he
shockingly keeps himself in relatively
decent shape for a retired president who
lives on a diet of fast food and diet
coke he actually seems to have a lot of
energy
and he doesn't let his emotions run away
with him when he's
making points even in the heat
of passion
he's always controlled
you've got the
nuclear maniac
kim jong-un
in north korea calling trump an old
daughter and threatening to blow up
america
and what does trump do does he react in
an emotional way
no he says oh little rocket man i would
never call him short and fat well i hope
he knows i've got a button and mine's
bigger ha ha he's always
he's crafting these jokes in a way
that tells you it's cool he's going to
let it roll off him he's he's
in command the same cannot be said of
joe biden joe biden seems like a man who
has no self-control at all he's
constantly contradicting himself he's
backtracking he's walking away he's
mumbling he's stumbling he's getting
really really angry and then he say in
that one sentence he'll get really angry
and go into shouty joe biden and then
he'll kind of calm down and trickle off
this it's the total opposite very often
presidents are followed by their
opposite and with trump you have a guy
who's very in command very boisterous
very
uh funny
and he's followed by this guy biden
who's kind of nothing who just blows
around in the wind he has no idea what
he believes and and that's why he'll
contradict himself and walk back his
policies again and again peter ducey
one of the few conservatives in the
white house press pool just asked joe
biden about his recent contradictions
especially the contradictions on ukraine
on the policy toward russia and on
potentially what could throw us into
world war iii and joe biden says i never
said that
are you worried that other leaders in
the world are going to start to doubt
that america is back if some of these
big things that you
say on the world stage keep getting
walked back
what's getting walked back it made it
sound like just in the last couple days
uh it sounded like you told us troops
they were going to ukraine
it sounded like you said it was possible
the us would use a chemical weapon and
it sounded like you were calling for
regime change in russia and we know
none of the three occurred
none of the three none of the three
none of the three occurred you didn't
hear that you're making that up peter
ducey that's not real i never said u.s
troops would go see ukraine i never
called for regime change in rush i
didn't do any of the roll the tape
and you're going to see when you're
there and if sometimes you've been there
you're going to see you're going to see
women
young people stand on stand in the
middle of the front damn tank
just saying i'm not leaving
i'm holding my ground
they're incredible for god's sake this
man cannot remain power and to clarify
on chemical weapons could if chemical
weapons were used in ukraine would that
trigger a military spot response from
nato
it would be it would trigger a response
in kind
it would trigger a response in kind
which means in the same way which means
a chemical attack
not only did joe biden say all of those
things that us troops were going to
ukraine
calling for regime change and ousting
vladimir putin and threatening to use
chemical weapons attack if russia used
one first not only did he say all of
those things but he apparently forgot he
said all of those things which is
believable because the guy doesn't know
what end is up most of the time but i
probably more likely he was just lying
and forgetting that we have the video
and then saying okay fine yeah you got
the video you heard these things don't
believe your lying eyes
don't believe your lying ears
this is the dishonesty of our ruling
class this is the corruption of our
ruling class i don't think that the
american people broadly
are particularly radical
i don't think the american people are
particularly corrupt i don't think the
american people are particularly vicious
quite the opposite actually i think the
american people are pretty virtuous
generally pretty interested in honesty
pretty reasonable
you see this
on the don't trans the kids bill right
the don't trans the kids bill in florida
that the ruling most americans support
that most americans support securing our
border most americans support a sensible
energy policy it's just a huge gap
between what the
americans a lot of mostly republicans
but a lot of democrats a lot of
independents a lot of moderates too what
they want which is normal ordinary good
stuff and what are
psychotic ruling class ones at this
point okay that is the battle can we
rest power back from the small group of
lunatics who are ruling us the next
six months 12 months looking into 2022
looking into 2024 that is what's going
to tell us do we have the self-control
do we have the poise do we have the
confidence and clarity of vision to take
our country back or has the left already
won i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
john vickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less join me and
my co-host georgia hal for daily
coverage of all the biggest stories on
morning wire